I started off on the baby slopes and surprisingly, I was actually able to stand up on the board.
I was so thinking I was gonna fall.
And then I felt pretty confident and somehow I got talked into going to this big mama sand dune.
Okay boys, what's next?
That is like a death warrant, basically.
But I don't know what came over me...
...but somehow I mustered up the courage to go flying down this huge sand dune.
No, I'm so scared!
I'm so scared.
I was flying down and I just heard someone say, "Just relax and enjoy the feeling."
And I'm like, "That's a really good idea, maybe I'll just do that."
And I was just flying and flying and I felt...
...I'm scraped here and I'm scraped here.
And I hit my chin but it was just like, it was awesome.
I've discovered something about myself today that I didn't know I had in me.
That's for sure.
I didn't know that I could have the guts to do that and then actually do it,...
...and still be in one piece.